en el vídeo pasado habíamos comenzado a
encontrar el área de las paredes de este
edificio de apariencia extraña aquí el
techo de este edificio estaba dado por
la función
efe de x que igual a x massieu cuadrada
y la base del edificio o más bien la
base de las paredes estaba dada de la
siguiente forma
primero recorríamos aquí un círculo de
radio 2 hasta llegar al eje y bajábamos
al origen y luego volteamos hacia la
izquierda para llegar al 20 el punto
inicial hasta el momento hemos logrado
encontrar el área de esta primer pared
de hecho vamos a pensarlo de la
siguiente forma en nuestro problema
original nos piden determinar la
integral de línea sobre la curva cerrada
le voy a poner aquí cerrada de la curva
ce de fx y
y en donde siempre multiplicamos fx por
una pequeña distancia de nuestra
trayectoria a esa le poníamos de ese
estamos escribiendo esto en la forma más
abstracta posible lo que comentábamos en
el vídeo pasado es que la forma más
fácil de resolver esto es dividiendo la
trayectoria en varios cachitos entonces
vamos a pensar que esta trayectoria que
se llama ce está dividida en una primera
parte se uno en una segunda parte de
aquí atrás c2 y va a ponerse 2 y en esta
última que le vamos a ponerse 3 entonces
podemos partir la integral esta de aquí
en pues tres integrales distintas voy a
ponerlo así como la integral sobre c 1
ya no es una integral cerrada de fx y de
s más la integral sobre c 2 d pues igual
verdad de fx y de s y la tercera la
integral sobre c 3 de fx
por d&s ya habíamos logrado determinar
la primer integral esta de aquí su área
nos había quedado cuatro más dos pi
entonces le pongo aquí cuatro más dos pi
ahora debemos encontrar las otras dos
partes entonces vamos a hacer dos vamos
a hacer esta integral que queda aquí en
medio para hacer eso debemos dar otra
parametrización para xy para allá pues
ya no estamos sobre el círculo de radio
2 va entonces vamos a ver cuánto debe
valer x pues siempre que estemos en c 2
x va a ser igual a 0 x es igual a 0
sobre el eje x siempre vale 0 ahora
vamos con ya a ver empieza en 2 verdad
voy a ponerle aquí un 2 y luego hay que
restar t y para qué valores después le
voy a poner 0 menor o igual a t y menor
o igual a 2 esto debe de funcionar
cuando te es cero estamos en este punto
y conforme crece y crece la trayectoria
se mueve hasta el punto de aquí que es
el origen va esa de ahí es la
parametrización para continuar vamos
encontrar las derivadas de esta
parametrización comencemos por la de x x
es igual a 0 entonces de x dt también es
igual a 0 listo y de tdt pues pues a ver
esto de aquí es la derivada de 2 - t la
derivada de 2 menos de con respecto a t
simplemente es menos 1 verdad entonces
nos queda menos 1 la derivada de 20 va
listo entonces nos queda lo siguiente
nos queda la integral sobre c 2 de una
vez el pongo los límites le voy a poner
desde 0 hasta 2 de fx y vamos a
cambiarlo de una vez
aver fx es esta expresión vamos a
ponerle x + d cuadrada
y finalmente x de ese pero sabes que de
una vez vamos a acordarnos de los vídeos
pasados y en vez de poner de ese vamos a
poner la raíz cuadrada de de x desde al
cuadrado entonces 0 al cuadrado más de 7
al cuadrado menos 1 al cuadrado es 1
todo eso dt fíjate estoy aquí nos queda
algo muy bonito pero al cuadrado es cero
más uno es uno y cuando le tomamos la
raíz se convierte en un 1 ahora
cambiamos a xy por un lado tenemos que x
siempre vale 0 entonces este término
podemos ignorarlo y por otro lado
tenemos que llevarle 2 - t entonces nos
quedan dos menos t al cuadrado entonces
toda esta expresión sota se simplificó a
la integral desde t igual a cero hasta t
igualados a ver la x ya desapareció
verdad x es igual a 0 sobre el eje y
luego tenemos que sumar ya cuadrada pero
ya es igual a 2 - t entonces nos queda 2
- t elevado al cuadrado y por supuesto
hay que poner un dt
listo entonces ya tenemos una integral
definida muy concreta que queremos
resolver primero hagamos la integral
indefinida a lo mejor se puede hacer
mentalmente pero mejor voy a hacer el
binomio al cuadrado aquí abajo a ver si
hago esto me queda la integral desde t
igual a 0 hasta t igualados de haber el
primero al cuadrado cuatro menos dos
veces el primero por el segundo cuatro t
más el segundo al cuadrado t cuadrada
pues por supuesto todo eso de verdad
ahora ya podemos integrar esta cosa
porque es una expresión polinomiales nos
queda la anti derivada de 4 que es 4 t
menos 2 t
sí verdad a 2 t cuadrada cuando
derivamos menos 2 de cuadrada que da
menos 4 t y luego hay que sumar hay que
sumar un tercio de t elevado al cubo
simplemente aumentamos el exponente y
luego dividimos entre el nuevo exponente
va ahora sí vamos a evaluar en 0 y en 2
en 2 es 4 por 2 que da 8 lo voy a poner
en otro color
8 - 2 por 2 al cuadrado a ver 2 al
cuadrado es 4 y 2 x 4 es 8 más un tercio
de 2 elevado al cubo eso es un tercio de
8 a ver vamos a simplificar esto 8 menos
8 nos queda 0 un tercio de 88 tercios y
luego tenemos que restar la expresión
evaluada en 0 pero aquí quedan puros 0
es verdad tenemos 40 menos 200 puros
ceros menos 10 entonces con eso ya
logramos encontrar el área de nuestra
segunda pared muy bien vamos acá arriba
aquí nos va a quedar ocho tercios
excelente ya solo falta la tercera pared
vamos a parametrizar la curva sobre la
cual está
creo que sería bueno poder ver el dibujo
mejor bajo y lo vuelvo a pegar listo
vamos con la tercera pared la integral
que hay que determinar es a ver es la
siguiente es la de aquí que es la
integral se llama base 3 aquí entonces
déjame ponerlo sobre mi integral
entonces tenemos la integral sobre c 3
de fx y de s que es igual a a ver vamos
a hacer una parametrización verdad sobre
c 3 vamos a poner que x es igual a t
para pues para t mayor o igual que 0 y
menor o igual a 2 y todo el tiempo que
me mueva en esta curva lleva a ser igual
a cero
entonces igual a cero entonces esto nos
va a quedar igual a la integral desde
este igual a cero hasta t igualados de
fx y ahora sí voy a poner la expresión
ahorita va a ponerlo en términos de xy a
ver es esta expresión de aquí x de s
ahora cuánto vale de s ahí pongo de ese
pero vamos a hacer esto desde ese aquí
arriba está entonces ya sabemos que de
ese es igual a la raíz cuadrada de de
equis dt elevado al cuadrado más de g dt
elevado al cuadrado por dt eso probamos
en los vídeos anteriores
bueno no rigurosamente pero dimos una
intuición de por qué se vaya bueno
cualidades derivada de x con respecto a
1 verdad 1 al cuadrado es 1 y luego la
derivada de ella con respecto al 0 0 al
cuadrado es 0 100 nos queda a raíz de 1
y entonces éste de ese simplemente se va
a convertir en un
de ese es igual dt en este caso
dt
ok la equis cuánto vale la equis es
igual a t eso viene de la definición de
la parametrización y es igual a cero
entonces vamos a ignorarla nos queda la
integral desde t igual a 0 hasta 2
dt bt listo eso es igual a haber la anti
derivada de t es un medio de t cuadrada
y luego hay que ponerle 0 y 2 eso es
igual a un medio por 2 al cuadrado es un
medio por 4 que nos quedan 2 y luego hay
que restar un medio por 0 que es 0 y
pues entonces simplemente nos queda nos
queda 2 verdad entonces el área de la
tercer pared simplemente es dos vamos a
escribirlo hasta acá arriba a ver aquí
lo voy a poner que el área es igual a 2
ok ahora sí ya tenemos las tres
integrales de línea vamos a la pregunta
original
cuál es la integral de línea sobre la
trayectoria c de fx y como ya dijimos
tenemos que sumar estos tres números a
ver tenemos pues ocho tercios lo vamos a
poner como dos y dos tercios tenemos
cuatro más
con dos tercios y 6 con dos tercios más
dos nos quedan ocho con dos tercios
entonces se vuelve ocho con dos tercios
y también tenemos que sumar un 2 y ahora
si terminamos terminamos estamos listos
para empezar a hacer integrales de línea
con campos vectoriales